say we have a right triangle
so let me draw my right triangle just
like that
this is our right triangle this is the
90 degree angle right here and we're
told that this this side's length right
here is 14 this side's length right over
here is nine and we're told that this
side is a
and we need to find the length of a so
as i mentioned already this is a right
triangle and we know that if we have a
right triangle we can always figure out
if we know two of the sides we can
always figure out a third side using the
pythagorean theorem what the pythagorean
theorem tells us is that the sum of the
squares of the shorter sides is going to
be equal to the square of the longer
side or the square of the hypotenuse and
if you're not sure about that you're
probably thinking hey sal how do i know
that a is shorter than this side over
here how do i know it's not 15 or 16 and
the way to tell is that the longest side
in a right triangle this only applies to
a right triangle is the side opposite
the 90 degree angle and in this case 14
is opposite the 90 degrees this 90
degree angle kind of opens into this
longest side the side that we call the
hypotenuse so now that we know that
that's the longest side let me color
code it so this is the longest side
this is one of the shorter sides and
this is the other of the shorter sides
the pythagorean theorem tells us that
the sum of the squares of the shorter
sides so a squared plus
9 squared
plus 9 squared is going to be equal to
14 squared it's really important that
you realize that it's not 9 squared plus
14 squared is going to be equal to a
squared a squared is one of the shorter
sides the sum of the squares of these
two sides are going to be equal to 14
squared the hypotenuse squared
and from here we just have to solve for
a so we get
a squared
plus 81
plus 81 is equal to 14 squared and in
case we don't know what that is let's
just multiply it out fourteen times
fourteen four times four is sixteen
four times one is four plus one is five
let's take a zero there one times four
is four
one times one is one six plus zero is
six five plus four is nine bring down
the one it's 196. so a squared plus 81
is equal to 14 squared which is 196.
then we could subtract 81 from both
sides of this equation let's subtract
81 from both sides on the left hand side
we're going to be left with just the a
squared these two guys cancel out whole
point of subtracting 81. so left with a
squared is equal to
minus 81.
196 minus 81. what is that see 190
so that if you just subtract 195 you
subtract 80 it'd be 100
115 if i'm doing that right right it
would be 115
and then to solve for a we just take the
square root of both sides the principal
square root the positive square root of
both sides of this equation
so let's do that because we're dealing
with distances you can't have a negative
square root or a negative distance here
and we get a is equal to the square root
of 115
a is equal to
the square root
of 115. now let's see if we can break
down 115 any further so let's see it's
clearly divisible by 5.
it's a if you factor it out it's 5 and
then what does it divide 5 goes into 115
23 times
23 times so both of these are prime
numbers so we're done so you actually
can't factor this anymore so a is just
going to be equal to the square root of
1 15. now if you want to get a sense of
roughly how large the square root of 115
is
if you think about the square root of
100 is equal to 10 and the square root
of 121
is equal to 11. so this value right here
is going to be someplace in between 10
and 11 which makes sense if you if you
think about it visually